aurélie et libraires indépendantes
depuis quelques temps elle vend beaucoup
de livres des livres bien précis alors
voilà ce sont les mangas qui booste les
ventes en librairie depuis un an depuis
le premier confinement les jeunes ont
beaucoup regardé d'animer qui sont des
mangas mis en mouvement en images et ça
leur a donné envie de lire ces histoires
les 15 25 ans nouveaux clients des
librairies à une époque où les ventes
étaient plutôt à la baisse bd manga mais
pas seulement on a aussi vendu beaucoup
de puzzle le puzzle a explosé
voilà trouver d'autres activités des
activités peut-être plus familial et
puis la lecture la lecture aussi pour
enfants beaucoup les périodes de
confinement propice à la lecture cette
habitante de sully sur loire en a
profité elle aussi on n'avait plus de
temps et puis en plus la librairie
malgré les fermetures et c'est à
continuer à faire du click and collect à
donner des conseils en ligne des avis
sur des conseils de lecture des avis
donc on les a suivis
ouais bah franchement si tu as aimé ça
tu aimeras qu'est ce que j'irais faire
au paradis et la décision c'est les
mêmes thématiques cinéma corps les gens
recentrent leurs activités c'est à dire
que ils ont plus de temps où il décide
de l'utiliser d'une autre manière voilà
je pense que le confinement leur a fait
prendre conscience de du temps qu'ils
avaient ou qu'ils n'avaient pas ou pas
beaucoup et qu'est ce qu'ils en font de
ce temps là voilà à quoi il va l'occuper
un regain pour la lecture apprécié
de quoi redonner le sourire aux
libraires